corndog lip-balm delicious it's all the
fun of corndogs with none of the
calories you know on second thought you
don't really want you with bone to smell
like corn dogs kind of a niche market
product just for Hank that was
uncomfortable let's try that again
that's good in other news we do have a
punishment for Hank cuz I did VidCon I
even make a video we probably make a
video every Monday Wednesday and Friday
into perpetuity you failed to make a
video but the bitching bit bit of
punishment
chicka-boom chicka-boom chicka-boom I
talk to I spend all day talking to an 18
month old child so you should be
grateful when I ever speak to you in
English by the way you're blocking the
view of the link that appreciates that
they could always see the link I'll be
over here it's seventy five hundred
sheets which is five percent no oh it's
like half a percent percent chance of
getting a Hank ler no it is five percent
so it's not a hey clerk fish I just made
that up
that is the best angler fish where's my
calculator I don't know seventy five
hundred one hundred fifty thousand
divided by seventy five hundred is five
percent right no it's twenty percent
according bangs calculator we're so good
at math that's five percent twenty is
five percent they wouldn't do that in a
shorter take your case you can't use all
of that yes someone said to me like the
surgery's no big deal after you get it
you'll feel like you did a thousand
crunches and I was like well yeah but it
sounds whole the thing is will you look
like you did a thousand crunches they
remove your gallbladder and install an
eight pack not even possible I don't
know is that no I don't think so you
just get the six and the last reason we
came to Montana is that you're my
brother and I I like you okay what is
this
Oh ma'am Oh scary
I can barely gonna look you in the eyes
it's far more comfortable just this way
and now we're back to just this way a
belated good morning Hank as you can
tell from the great speckled walls
behind me I'm in an airport on my way
home there Thunder sorry for the ethics
video but one last thing before I get on
the plane we're a big fan of Michael
what the buck Buckley so much so that we
are stealing his buck Factor idea so
nerdfighters if you've been an awesome
video recently that you feel like
deserves a wider audience make it a
video response below and you will go and
watch all of them and feature a few in a
future vlog brothers video Hank thanks
for hosting us in Missoula don't forget
to be awesome I will see you on Monday